well a standoff involving a hostage ends
with a man in custody in the southeast
valley this all happened not far from
woodbury middle school by harmon and
sandhill hector mehia joins us live from
the scene and hector i understand
students are safe police say this all
started with a welfare check not very
far from that middle school
this had nothing to do with the students
but with the campus being so close to
the scene ccsd police assisted and
according to metro police a welfare
check here at a home along this block
escalated to a three-hour standoff the
suspect said he had a woman hostage and
her cameras were rolling when all of
this finally came to an end
neighbors heard what was likely the end
of an hours-long police standoff near
sand hill and harmon before nine o'clock
tuesday morning i was at a bus stop a
few blocks away with my elementary
school
child waiting for their bus and
that was when we heard a couple booms
a ccsd parent did not want to be
identified but said students were
detoured away from the scene and still
allowed to attend class she has an
elementary school student and a seventh
grader at woodbury middle school i was
worried about walking her all the way to
school and actually leaving her at
school one block south of the middle
school is where a welfare check
escalated to the standoff metro police
also say that around 5 30 a.m the
suspect had a woman hostage it finally
ended with his arrest more than three
hours later
and police have not yet released the
name of the suspect or the list of
charges he now faces we also have not
heard back from the clark county school
district about whether or not the school
was ever placed on lockdown reporting
live hector mejia live local now